Cyclone Kenneth makes landfall in Mozambique,...
...dumping heavy rain on the African nation and ripping off roofs.
At least one person is reported dead.
Another cyclone, Idai, devastated the country six weeks ago.
In Sri Lanka, Malcolm Ranjith, Catholic Archbishop of Colombo,...
....says he feels "betrayed" by the government's failure to act on warnings...
...that could have prevented the Easter bombings.
In Brazil, thousands of indigenous Brazilians marched in the country's capital of Brasilia...
...to protest ministerial changes they say are hurting their people.
In the US, admitted Russian agent Maria Butina has been sentenced to 18 months' prison...
...and faces deportation upon release.
Finally from Sudan, thousands of Sudanese protesters converge on Sudan's army headquarters...
...following Friday prayers, demanding the military rulers cede power.